peut bien fabriquer au cœur de l'Ariège
c'est simple c'est la nouvelle résidence
secondaire de Marie pour sa retraite
cette fête 68 heures a décidé de quitter
le plus souvent possible sa cuisine
équipée parisienne pour cette yaourt de
20 mètres carrés beaucoup de nature un
petit air de Mongolie et un intérieur au
final plutôt cossu marie vient ici
quelques semaines de temps à autre mais
elle ne sait pas transformée pour autant
un apôtre d'une vie 100% rustique il y a
une certaine satisfaction à réinventer
le chauffage on peut bricoler bon tout
ça c'est très hypocrite parce qu'en fait
on se passerait absolument pas de ça
mais se donner ce sentiment de temps en
temps qu'on peut on peut on peut vivre
sans qu'on n'est pas aliéné
s'il y a pas le central c'est pas la
télé s'il y a pas ça pas le téléphone
marine n'est pas la seule à avoir
succombé au charme de cette drôle de
tente dans laquelle les Mongols eux
vivent pour de bon 140 jours se sont
vendus cette année pour 4000 euros on
vous la livre en kit après il n'y a plus
qu'à la montée tout simplement
dans un autre style du chic plus fou du
glamour plus haut plus 15 mètres du sol
la cabane
ils adorent jusqu'à dire vous vous
sentez un oiseau mais presque parceque
beaucoup plus cher une cabane à 70 000
euros qu'il
aurait cru